Britain in the end was not prepared to
become a province of a country called
Europe we want to have the best and
closest relations with our neighbors
they will remain our friends and our
allies and our suppliers and our
customers but we want to live under our
own walls just like any other country
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro shows Sunday special with Daniel
Hannan he's the president of the
initiative for free trade and a UK
member of the EU Parliament Daniel
thanks so much for stopping here Ben
it's great to be here I'm a big fan well
thank you I appreciate it back at you so
let's jump right in obviously what's at
the forefront of every person's mind
when they hear your accent is what is
happening with brexit so what is sort of
the latest there yeah well I'm the only
person in this conversation who doesn't
have an accent right what's happening
with look what's happening with breaks
it is that two years ago two years ago
there was an election during which every
major party promised to uphold the
referendum result it's now clear that
one of those two parties didn't mean it
the Labour Party have done everything
they can to frustrate it
so we've had years of postponement and
delay and it is making people crazy and
one of the things that is infuriating is
you have people saying bricks it has
divided the country breaks it has made
you all mad breaks it has set people it
breaks it hasn't happened I mean do I
need to spell this out
the thing that is dividing the country
of cetera et cetera et cetera is exactly
the opposite it is the refusal of
members of parliament to do what they
promised and honor the result so there
have been a lot of folks who have been
uttering the word brexit president Trump
obviously says brexit a lot i don't know
that very many people know exactly what
brexit is what drove it what is the
history of brexit why is it happening
why did the British population vote for
it if the European Union would just a
club if it were just a trade association
if it were a group of neighboring
countries wanting to do things together
there have been no referendum there have
been no argument ready to have you'd
have to be crazy to have a problem with
that the problem was that the EU didn't
stop there it wanted ultimately to
become a country called Europe and one
by one it acquired all of the attributes
and trappings of a nation-state
it has a flag it has a national anthem
it has a passport a parliament a
president a Supreme Court external
borders representation at the UN
developing military can
Basti a criminal justice system what it
doesn't have is a sense of nationhood it
doesn't have a sense of shared identity
or affinity among the people that can
sustain these organizations so britain
in the end was not prepared to become a
province of a country called europe we
want to have the best and closest
relations with our neighbors they will
remain our friends and our allies and
our suppliers and our customers but we
want to live under our own laws just
like any other country so how did the EU
make this shift because originally it
was just supposed to be sort of an
economic bonding together wasn't it
there were always people who wanted a
federal state of Europe right from the
start but the real shift came at the
beginning of the 90s when the the Treaty
of Maastricht was passed and that was
when it stopped being the European
Economic Community and became the
European Union and that was when it
acquired the flag and the trappings and
attributes of statehood and that really
was the birth of modern British
Euroskeptics ISM up until then there'd
been a tiny remnant of the mainly of the
trade unions and the far left had always
been against it but euro scepticism was
not a thing until the early 90s and as
the EU has gone further and further
towards political amalgamation Britain
has gone in the other direction how was
it allowed to progress so fast I mean it
really did progress pretty quickly I
mean Britain was one of the only
countries in the EU that maintained its
own currency and therefore was was able
to survive the economic crash in a way
that was better than the rest of the EU
and a lot of the pressures that were
inside of the the EU why did things
escalate this quickly inside the year
it's become I think almost a religion
fault so it began of course from good
motives right I mean like almost
everything in politics when we're not
dealing with evil people we're dealing
with people who have good intentions but
have made miscalculations and the good
intention behind the EU was the only way
to stop wars in Europe and to get
everyone to get on is to kind of pull
the Institute's of their of their
statehood to have a bigger sovereignty
that covers all of the the old ones some
of them look to the example of the US
but that the big difference of course is
that in the US people were already
starting with one language with
basically compatible religion with the
same legal system and with us a sense
shared identity which of course is not
the case in Europe and and so you can't
the way I'd put it is this if you want a
democracy you have to have a demos you
have to have a unit with which we
identify when we say the word we right
it's it's what well my friend Roger
Scruton calls the politics of the first
person pearl you've got to have that
sense of community and if you if you
take the demos away then you're left
only with the cratis we're only with the
power the power of the system that has
to compel by force of law what it can't
ask in the name of patriotism because
there is no common Patridge ism because
no one really feels European in the same
sense that somebody might feel Hungarian
or Swedish or Portuguese Jonas they can
only ask you about sort of the
particular driving force behind brett's
it was at immigration was it economic
first let's talk about being an adult
part of adulthood is having to do things
that you really do not want to do like
red-eye flights working late visiting
in-laws and getting life insurance but
another part of adulthood is learning to
delegate what you hate and well you
can't delegate a visit to the in-laws
you can certainly delegate life
insurance shopping policy genius is the
easy way to shop for life insurance
online in just two minutes
you can compare quotes from top insurers
and find your best price once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and the red tape no sales
pressure no hidden fees just financial
protection and peace of mind policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they also help you find the right
home insurance and auto insurance and
disability insurance all types of
insurance so if you need life insurance
but you don't want to deal with all the
legwork head over to policy genius.com
it's the easy way to compare all the top
insurers find the best value for you
policy genius delegate what you hate
especially if you hate getting life
insurance also listen I know you don't
want to think about death but just do it
for five seconds go get your life
insurance over a policy genius calm get
it taken care of
be an adult policy genius calm so let's
talk for a second about what exactly was
the driving force behind all this so the
EU is gaining power they're obviously
issuing a lot of regulations and it
seems like the media coverage has
focused in on one specific area of
European integration that is immigration
the idea that there is this open
immigration movement particularly
springing from Angela Merkel in Germany
and this freedom of movement inside the
EU where people could basically set on
where they want and move across borders
freely how much of brexit was driven by
immigration concerns and how much of it
was driven by
pressures or over-regulation from
Brussels well we had quite a lot of
polling data on this including a massive
exit poll on the day of more than 12,000
people it was a really big data set and
so we don't need to speculate we asked
and the answer was the top issue for
people with sovereignty the top issue
was the principle of wanting to live
under their own laws to hire and fire
the people who passed those rules
immigration was an issue it was one of
many areas where people wanted control
back but it was not the issue in the way
that you would think if you rely on
reports from the New York Times the
Financial Times The Economist or the BBC
in fact I will give you a general rule
of thumb ban a heuristic as we might
pretentiously call it if any Brit says
to you bricks it was all about
immigration I guarantee that you're
talking to someone who voted remain
because Leivers know that that wasn't
really the issue that the issue was
democracy of which immigration was one
subset so what that said you know when
when looking at the media coverage of
this the media basically covered this as
a xenophobic backlash to immigration of
course and they also suggest that this
is part of a broader global populist
uprising of which President Trump yes
was a person it's much much easier to
dismiss your opponents than to engage in
any self analysis right so I mean there
is a parallel universe somewhere where
the media and indeed the Eurocrats in
Brussels might have said oh I wonder why
they voted leave I wonder whether we
might have played that a bit better I
wonder whether other people might not
like us and maybe we should be a little
bit more flexible but of course nobody
likes to do that nobody likes to
question whether they got something
wrong it's always more tempting to say
bunch of xenophobes it was all about not
liking you know different races or not
liking immigration and then you don't
have to think you don't have to question
yourself at all and that's now sort of
built up this head of seam I mean it's
become almost an article of faith among
the remain media that there was a spike
in racially aggravated crime this turns
out to be absolute rubbish there was a
there's a police kind of hotline where
people are encouraged to say I'm a
victim of hate crimes there was a spike
in the 96 hours after the vote which
turned out to be a lot of people
complaining about the leave campaign and
yet this is now solemnly reported
everywhere as
the spike in hate crimes that have
followed the referendum and even to
question that is now taking on kind of
canonical force even to say there was no
spike in hate crimes people are more Pro
immigration than they were before the
result Britain is is more Pro
immigration than almost any country in
Europe you know the number of cases
referred to for prosecution is falling
even to say those things is well what is
it you'd like to say facts don't care
about your feelings right
these are hate facts simply to recite
the facts is is to open yourself to the
accusation of being as nfo bore a racist
or whatever so you mentioned the remain
media maybe you could give sort of a
breakdown as to how the media works in
Britain so I famously was was unaware of
how the media works in Britain based on
my labeling of particularly the BBC so I
know that the BBC is state-funded I knew
that the BBC leans left I know there are
publications like The Guardian that
obvious have a large online presence and
lean left but what what is the breakdown
in media in the UK and how does that
impact right so the newspapers are
fairly balanced in terms of the numbers
of titles left to right and Pro 20 you
and by the way that second fissure has
now become the dominant cultural one in
Britain really really weird thing people
are much more likely to self define as
leave or remain than they are as labour
or conservative or left or right but the
the broadcast media are overwhelmingly
one way there is no Fox there's no
there's no plurality right and by the
way I'm not someone who says foxes is
always fair and balanced I don't think
any any medium can be no you're not I'm
not you know we've all got our point of
view we all bring assumptions to the
table but the the the the best you can
have in a in a world where your bias is
my accuracy or whatever the best you can
have is its pluralism right yes I have a
cacophony of lots of different
interpretations and then out of that
people can kind of gauge what they think
is true when it comes to the broadcast
media in the UK that simply doesn't
exist there is a single way of looking
at the world which is soft left right so
it's not it's not violently
revolutionary left like Jeremy Corbyn
but you know it has a number of fixed
assumptions immigration good Israel bad
you know welfare good austerity bad and
and it's created a climate where if you
say something else
it sounds jarring and that makes life
much easier if you're on the left so in
a second I want to ask you about the
differences between sort of left and
right in America versus left and right
in in Britain and the divisions that are
now increasing between labour and
conservative party as the labour party
moves incredibly radical first I want to
ask you one more question about brexit
and that is now that we've had this
brexit vote what's the holdup so the EU
obviously is attempting to leverage
Britain into staying basically revoking
its own referendum which seems to me
pretty good justification for the brexit
campaign in the first place of course I
mean if the complaint is that the EU is
a democratic right yeah I don't anyone
now doubt that right exactly exactly
basically what happened was that when
the Conservatives lost their majority at
the win when Teresa may lost the
conservative majority in 2017 there was
then a majority in parliament that was
saying quite publicly we will not leave
except on terms laid down by the EU we
are not prepared to walk away from the
table
now imagine any negotiation right
imagine you were buying a house or a car
and you said listen before we even start
talking I want you to understand that I
will not walk away from the table what's
the other guy gonna do right and that's
basically what happened the British
Parliament said we will leave only on
terms that you the EU agree at which
point of course the EU said oh well in
that case here are some much tougher
terms and if you don't like that stay of
course they did I mean I kind of can't
blame them for that right ultimately I
suspect that may mean we will need
another general election fought
specifically on this issue because if
Parliament will not leave on time in the
way that it promised to when it
triggered the whole process you have to
change the majority in parliament okay
so a lot of the media coverage was
suggestive of the idea that the brexit
campaign was led by a bunch of people
who are anti free trade there's a bunch
of people who were interested in cutting
off trade ties with the EU that they
were economic isolationist that they
were sort of Trump being in their
approach to dude tariffs you're
obviously of a group that is free trade
that is so the opposite of the truth in
all of the material we put out we would
say here are three reasons to vote leave
or five reasons to vote leave or ten
reasons to vote leave depending on how
long the pamphlet was always one of them
was free a trade with the world this was
this wasn't something we sneaked out in
the small print I mean
we were absolutely clear about this and
that is a big difference between the
Trump campaign here and the the brexit
campaign in the UK I mean sure of course
necessarily there were some similarities
because they were both kind of
anti-establishment and and they both
played on a sense that the elites had
failed but as I understand it a big part
of Donald Trump's stick here was we
don't want free trade with China where
is a huge part of the leave campaign was
we do want free trade with China and
with America and with India and all the
other places that we don't have because
the EU is too protectionist and one of
the huge advantages that I hope will
come out of BRICS it is deep
comprehensive free trade between the UK
and the US we're already each other's
biggest trading partners were already
each other's biggest investors you know
of course because of the affinities of
language and law and all the rest of it
I mean but up until now we haven't been
able to sign a free trade agreement and
what I really hope is that when we do
it's not just gonna you know Donald
Trump says it's not just gonna be a
trade it you can imagine how he puts it
he is gonna be a beautiful incredible
freedom don't want those trade right do
you know what this time it really could
be true all those superlatives of his
may on this occasion be justified
because if we did a trade agreement or
we just said whatever is legal in your
country is automatically legal in ours
and vice versa right so you get away
from all the common standards all the
common regulation all the bureaucracy
all the cartels or the corporatism and
you just say if a drug is approved by
the FDA that's good enough for us if a
guy is qualified to work as a trader in
the City of London he can automatically
work on Wall Street
think of how that would bring down costs
remove regulations work for the little
guy and set it for the big corporate and
that would be a different way of doing
trade so for American viewers obviously
we've been focused in on brexit but
there are some other issues in Britain
that have obviously taken center stage
one of those has been the radical move
to the left of the Labor Party which is
now led by basically a communist Jeremy
Corbyn and an anti-semitic communist at
that what happened to the Labour Party
here in Britain which used to be of Tony
Blair and is now Jeremy Corbyn it's
absolutely extraordinary that the when
you say basically a communist I mean
this is a guy who regrets the outcome of
the Cold War and I'm not saying that as
a political slogan I'm saying it as an
observable fact of his political
development right
this is a guy who at the last election
was asked would you ever have been on
our side in any conflict right
no not raising the bar very high right I
mean you aspire to leave the country
when would you be on on the on the side
of the country you aspire to lead he had
to really think cuz this is a guy who's
Pro I are a pro Hamas Pro his alar
pro-castro Pro Chavez even in the
Falklands War you'd have thought if
there was any regime on the planet that
someone on the Left would have hated it
would have been a fascist junta that
locked up trade unionists and murdered
left-wing activists right but of course
as soon as they were all with us no no
no we couldn't criticize it so we had to
really think and you could see that the
the process going on it and then like a
little boy who gets the right answer in
class he goes hey at the Second World
War and I was thinking yeah after June
1941 right when silence which side then
and then maybe you would have been on
our side and not because it was our side
actually do you know what a really funny
thing that I discovered his father who
was a communist in in at that time did
exactly that right say he was on the he
was against us when the Nazis and the
Soviets were on the same side and then
he switched when Hitler attacked Stalin
like like like almost all British
communists did right it is by the way an
incredible cultural victory for the left
this massive active amnesia that we all
forget that Hitler and Stalin were on
the same side for fully a third of the
entire so how did this happen how did
Jeremy Corbyn end up at the head of this
I guess the short answer is from the 80s
labor began to expel the the hardline
Trotskyist militants and the rules were
changed under the previous labor leader
because they'd been a scandal in in the
selection of a candidate in a siege in
Scotland and the then Labour leader Ed
Miliband said well let's open the doors
so that more people have a say over who
the the MP is and who the leader is and
basically these kind of probably 200,000
people who were really on the fringe
left at proper Marxist left came
flooding back in or flooding in in the
case of the younger ones and although
200,000 is tiny you know in a nation of
65 million
it is huge for a political party and so
even if Jeremy Corbyn were tomorrow to
be hit by that proverbial bus that is so
lethal and is always running over
political leaders in our in our
imagination same electorate would pick
another core Binet and I mean I I can't
tell you how strange this is how outside
our experience it is I mean we've had a
fairly moderate Party of the center-left
compared to almost any European country
you know it wasn't revolutionary it
wasn't Marxist it was it was born out of
nonconformist churches and the
temperance movement and brass bands and
workingmen's libraries it was all about
building up the working man and
spreading opportunity it was not a
violent revolutionary party unlike most
places you don't have to look too far to
see a different model and suddenly we
have got a doctrinaire Marxist who you
know III won't say that he is himself an
anti-semite yeah I always think he looks
like a rather scruffy reformed rabbi
actually but he has he has opened the
door to believable people and I just
think this is really interesting that it
was people denied it for a long time
they couldn't bring themselves to admit
that labour had a problem with
anti-semitism which is totally new I
mean we of course Britain like every
country like the u.s. like France why
anyways had some anti-semites down the
years but we have never until now had
them infiltrate one of the main parties
this is completely unprecedented in
Britain and I think the reason that they
got away with it for a long time is that
there's this kind of funny
jae-joon view out there now especially
to young people that right-wing means
intolerant and left-wing means nice and
therefore since anti-semites are
intolerant they can't be on the left as
I don't need to tell you Ben of all
people that is such a falsification of
history you know that the guy who
invented the word anti-semitism was a
socialist the guy who invented the word
socialism was mantasy might you know in
the late 19th century this was again
wasn't it wasn't common to the whole
left but it was a very very natural
thing to have revolutionary socialist
parties who said capitalists and Jews
are the problem they're grinding now the
working
man you know in 1920 Hitler says to his
party members how as the Socialists can
you not be an anti-semite and nobody
thought it an odd thing to say in those
days right it's it's the the strange
cultural victory of the left that these
these phrases now sound so jarring
because you know how can you be a nice
lefty and think this thing they did for
a long time not all of them of course it
was it the word there was an honorable a
pluralist tradition on the left there
were lots of Jewish socialists and all
that right but going right back to Karl
Marx there was this other tradition as
well of seeing anti-semitism as an
extension of of anti capitalism and that
is what's come flooding back in to the
Labor Party this idea that we're against
kind of Rothschilds taking over the
world and it it is not something you
find on the right it's something that is
almost exclusively now on the left so
let's talk for a second about the the
left's moves on multiculturalism which
seemed to me to have some ties to
anti-semitism in Europe I mean having
visited Europe the making room for folks
who really despised Jews and by this I
mean some radical Muslim immigrants who
have been unvetted the the radical rise
in hate crimes against Jews in places
ranging from France to Sweden which in
many cases is linked undeniably to arise
in an unvetted population of radical
Muslims coming from a part of the world
where Jews are particularly hated does
that have any linkage with it with the
labor parties move on anti-semitism well
are these unrelated it's a really
interesting question I think that the
left in Britain and in the US and in
Europe has now got itself into this
strange obsession with a brand of
identity politics that is really about
imagined hierarchies of privilege or
imagined pyramids of oppression or
whatever you want to call it and they
it's a it's an incredibly kind of
pre-enlightenment way of seeing the
world that you are defined by the birth
of by the caste or the race that you're
born with you know and the and you know
you guys in some ways are ahead of
anywhere else on this but but our labor
party has got into it and so it has good
categories and bad categories and
generally if you're an immigrant you're
in a in a good category what's happened
and why the
or has been open to anti-semitism on the
left is that in this imagined hierarchy
of oppression the left can no longer
tell itself that Jews are an oppressed
you know discriminated against wretched
minority that suffers from penal laws
and all the rest of it success of the
State of Israel and the success of
Jewish people throughout the
english-speaking world in particular
makes it difficult to to maintain this
imagined pyramid in your mind and so
with the sticking up for the little guy
thing as they would see it suddenly Jews
have found themselves on the wrong side
of the of the imagined pyramid and I
think it's probably that's the linkage
if you like it's the beginning of this
is reimagines of racial identity
politics so do you think that it's
left-wing anti-semitism that is leading
to the left's hatred of Israel or do you
think it's vice versa or do they feed
each other because one of the things
that is obviously notable about Europe
is the entire European attitude toward
Israel which is extraordinarily hateful
and terrible over all there there are
some exceptions but it seems like
there's pretty broad agreement that
Israel is the bad guy across Europe
where is that comment look first of all
every country sometimes deserves
criticism yours does mine does Israel
does right so so I'm not I'm not saying
that you should never criticize Israel
or any other country but you're right
there is a disproportionate focus on a
pretty tiny strip of land which compared
to its neighbors is doing pretty well if
you'd have thought in terms of human
rights democracy you know inclusiveness
etc where does that come from a lot of
American friends and a lot of Israeli
friends of mine say it's anti-semitism
or it's anti Americanism and there's an
element of truth in that but I think the
bigger factor is this the European ideal
is based on the premise that national
loyalties are arbitrary transient and
ultimately discreditable that the
nation-state is a bad thing the
nationalism causes war and ethnic
conflict and all the rest of it and you
know we should all be transcending the
ocean station forming these big
supranational unions that's that's the
that's the EU story in a nutshell now
there is no stronger rebuke of that
ideology than the story of Israel
here is a people who are for 2,000 years
stateless and scattered but who never
lose the aspiration of nationhood next
year in Jerusalem and then one day
against all the odds providentially you
might say they achieve it now I look at
that story most American you know
politicians look at that's all I say
there's a great uplifting story you know
how fantastic good triumphs against all
the odds but if your starting point is
that the national principle is the root
of all evil then you're you're bound to
be triggered by it and ultimately I
think that's why Israel is always gonna
fight to get a fair hearing in Brussels
is because simply by existing it
undermines the whole basis of the
European project so let's talk for a
second about the conservative parties
who talked about sort of the
shortcomings of the Labor Party
first of all most Americans here
conservative party and they think ok
American conservative what are the
differences between European
conservative parties European right-wing
parties and the American Republican
Party or American conservative ideology
do you think well that depends what you
mean by Europe so I'm British rather
than European our conservative party I
think is fairly analogous to your
Republican Party in his good and it's
bad ways but in Europe especially in
continental Europe it's a different
story you have Christian Democratic
parties that tend to be culturally of
the right but economically much more of
the center or center left and then you
have liberal parties which are
economically to the right but are
culturally to the central center left so
we as British conservatives struggled
for a long time to find a neat fit in
continental Europe there were no obvious
allies for us we've now found some it
from Scandinavia and from Eastern Europe
in particular but not really so much
from the old core EU countries and the
Christian Democrat parties that are
called the main you know Angela Merkel's
party or you know the Dutch Christian
Democrats or whatever they are I mean
they're pretty you know as that great
Californian honor of Schwarzenegger
would say these up these are girly men
conservatives these are pantywaist
observed they are not so they're not
conservatives as you and I would would
understand so when it comes to the UK
Conservative Party what do what is the
I believe the role of government is so
it seems like the NHS for example is
completely untouchable by both sides of
the political aisle in Great Britain
obviously that is an issue of tremendous
import in the United States when it
comes to the role of government in
healthcare where the Republican Party
used to and I hope still will the future
for the future will stand against
nationalized healthcare but increasingly
both parties are moving ads around you
know the weirdest thing about that is
that in both countries
defenders of I mean III don't think
either of our countries has an
especially good health care system right
I mean there are many many better models
out there than either the American or
the British system and yet in both
countries defenders of the status quo
have done an incredibly good job of
pretending that the other country is the
only alternative so any proposal to
reform the NHS is all right you want an
American system and similarly here any
any move away from the old system is
either either Canada or Britain well you
know there are countries with way better
health outcomes than either yours or
ours and way better value for muscle in
Yeah right right loads and and and and
in all these places you know you are not
denied health care because you're poor
it's just that the but if you can't
afford it
you're you don't get treated as a
supplicant you're you're a consumer and
you tend to get much better value and
much better treatment and and it it
works out particularly in Singapore I
mean they've got incredibly good
outcomes compared to anybody else
healthier population and it's a much
better place to be poor right in terms
of health outcomes I mean at every level
you're better off in Singapore but you
know we've got the same we've got the
same spread you know we have the same
electoral system as you our right or
centre party like yours is a coalition
it's got some great people and some bad
people and I tell you one thing that I
think is is is going to be where we move
in your direction as we record this
interview we're two weeks away from
knowing who the the Tory leader is but
I'm going to go out on a limb and I may
look an idiot when this is broadcast but
I'm going to go out on a limb and say
the Boris Johnson is likely to be
elected and will be Prime Minister I
think we're gonna see something very
similar to the culture war prompted by
Donald Trump I don't mean to imply that
that Boris is like Donald Trump in
character or personality they are very
very different people Boris is one of
the cleverest people
from that and I don't I don't just mean
in politics I mean in life he is a
brilliant brilliant man who is clever
enough to understand that that can
intimidate people so he clowns around a
little bit and puts those people at
their ease and it's you know it's it
kind of polite right whereas I don't
think that he's true of Donald Trump he
is keen to tell everyone what a genius
he is but I get to see much independent
evidence having said that they do have
this in common they're both kind of
outside their parties and they both
polarize opinion and very quickly the
culture war ceases to be about them and
becomes about whether you like the or
dislike the other side right and and and
I don't think that's a good thing I
don't think it's been good for you and I
don't think it's gonna be good for us
but it's the way it's the way politics
is moving so speaking of President Trump
you're obviously not from the United
States what is what is sort of the
conservative British view of President
Trump his performance his personality
and sort of speakings of the future of
conservatism along those lines I you
know I I think you are about the only
popular commentator in the u.s. who gets
this right one of the things that really
alarms me is that you can't express any
kind of modulated view on this now you
know without being held down so have you
take it take a statement that would have
been completely uncontroversial during
the primary is like it's wonderful that
Trump is cutting taxes but he shouldn't
have lied about releasing his own tax
return or how fantastic to have him
getting on top of the administrative
state but you shouldn't insult the
family of a dead servicemen right my
point is not that these are true or
false nobody's you never hear them you
never hear them because nobody apart
from you is is even trying to be
balanced about this and it shouldn't be
impossible to say yes you know he's
doing some good things and some bad
things like like every other human being
part of the problem is that of course
the left one were countenance that they
they've he said this into a moral battle
in and he's evil and frankly part of the
problem is that he doesn't like it
either
he doesn't want conditional support he
doesn't want people to say I support you
when I agree with you he insists in a
quite needy way on getting people who
support him when he does is 180 degrees
flips them so that that means it's very
difficult to have a kind of moderate
view on this
and I don't know I was just reading
Jonah Goldberg's book about the state of
current politics and he makes the point
that autocracy or wanting wanting to
follow a strong man on his own account
rather than because of what he stands
for it's actually a very natural
condition of human government you know
we were monarchies for almost the whole
of the last ten thousand years and when
we stopped formally being monarchies we
very quickly went back to having the
strong guy in fact you know I think we
it's not just that we we we have this in
our past when we imagine the future when
we when we write you know Star Wars look
we fill it with Emperor's and princesses
right it's almost like that is the
natural human condition and I think this
is what Franklin meant by if you can
keep it right it's the u.s. is
extraordinary in that it has created a
system of checks and balances where
autocracy is difficult but just because
just because you've managed for a couple
hundred years doesn't mean that what
you're doing is is natural is not it it
runs up against human instincts and
intuitions and one of the things that
really worries me is how easily people
can go back to authoritarianism I guy
not your guy tribalism it's happened
here with a rapidity that I found
astonishing and it's happening all over
the Western world so how do we keep this
anachronism going I mean given the fact
that people seem to want to follow the
strongman given the fact that the only
type of politics people actually want to
talk about is not the legislative
sausage-making or even the party
interplay what they really want to talk
about is the leadership right here we've
only talked about Donald Trump we've
talked about Boris Johnson we talked
about Jeremy Corbyn namely the
quote/unquote big men right of politics
how do we have any unlikely big men
right they imagine any of them is like a
dictator right they're classic sort of
fictional dictator they are fit I don't
know which of them is the least costly
here's the thing you and I are products
of an education system that and and most
people watching that taught us a bunch
of counterintuitive and counter-cyclical
ideas for example the notion that
someone that you don't like may still
have something useful to say that is a
really difficult idea it does not come
naturally it were we're much more prone
to
with our tribal heuristic of my site
good your site bad and you have to be
taught that you have to be taught the
scientific method you have to be taught
empiricism you have to be taught this
difficult idea of assessing something by
whether it's true rather than by whether
you like the guy saying it I don't think
we're doing that now I think not only in
and most obviously in universities but
actually in in secondary education as
well we are instead of teaching these
counter-cyclical ideas that make an open
society and republican government
possible we're doing the opposite we're
teaching identity politics were going
back to the pre-modern idea that you're
defined by the circumstances of your
birth and I think that is turning our
backs on the Enlightenment I think it's
a really alarming trait and I'm
generally hugely optimistic about the
world and about the US but this is the
thing that worries me more than almost
anything else because having having
built this extraordinary miracle where
we are able to change governments
peacefully without anyone being exiled
or shot where you have free speech and
free assembly and private property and
all the rest of it if you lose that the
idea that it's just gonna happen again
when it really only happens the one time
in 10,000 years it is kind of a big
gamble so we've you've got to constantly
work to keep our system going constant
repair work constant husbandry and and
in particular that means teaching people
all the time you know you can disagree
with someone without his being an enemy
our opponents are not our enemies well
this is one of the things that I find so
odd about sort of our modern politics we
focus a lot on what government is doing
what government actors are doing but it
seems like the important work is being
neglected this is sort of the the upkeep
of the ditches to make sure the
irrigation is flowing that the social
fabric that requires stitching that is
being allowed to fray meanwhile we're
focusing on sort of clubbing each other
at the governmental level it's become
what Barack Obama suggested in 2012 the
only thing that we have in common is
government which means that if the only
tool of power is government and the only
thing we have in common is government
then control of government becomes the
only friend whereas if you really don't
care about government that much then you
can say we disagree about government and
that's that and we leave each other
alone and we can live in a society the
more powerful government becomes the the
less we are allowed to disagree with
each other unless we undermine the the
basis of the state itself I mean
I still think there is there is an
immense job of Education to be done and
that is that's partly a question of
formal schooling but it's also I think
partly a question of you know we are
civilized by families in the first
instance Hannah Arendt had this lovely
phrase where she said every generation
the West is invaded by barbarians
they're called children right so so we
arrive with the same basic mental kit
that that a baby would have had fifty
thousand years ago right the the thing
that makes us what we are rather than
hunter-gatherers and and you know
vengeful and violent and all the rest of
it in the first place is what we learn
in our families and then what we learn
in in in schools and and by imitating
norms of other people and to be honest I
think the West is kind of falling down
on all those things at the moment and
and we're storing up a heap of trouble
so let's talk about one of the things
that I think a lot of conservatives in
the United States look at Europe and are
deeply worried by because you know for
me as a conservative I look at Europe
and I said okay that we're always 50
years behind whatever Europe has going
so Europe can be 50 years more toward
the cliff and we will be there soon
enough and you see this in terms of
spending habits Tories in terms of
health care systems and you see this in
terms of sort of social institutions as
well European religion began its long
slow it seems irreversible decline in in
the 1910s 1920s and then that pursued a
pace by by the time you hit post-world
War two religion and Europe has
basically hit low up and then continued
to drop even beyond that in the United
States you're seeing late-breaking
irreligion you're seeing secularism rise
it's now the the single the the single
sex that is most identified with is
unaffiliated in the United States about
25 26 percent of the population and it
seems to me that that is reflected in
our politics that that if people don't
believe in the notion of god-given
rights if people don't believe in the
notion of a social fabric that exists
outside of government which used to
exist in churches that that's very bad
news number one do you see a substitute
for religion in Europe that is rising
number two do you see anything like a
religious revival on the on the road in
Europe these things kind of happen right
I mean there was a religious revival in
the late 18th early 19th century in
Britain there was kind of like the Great
Awakening here these things can go in
waves but
I would say it's not intrinsically
impossible to carry on being a
successful confident society with a
lower number of people who are
churchgoers as long as you have other
values that bind the country together
and you know throughout the 20th century
although rates of church attendance fell
in Britain life generally got better
people got richer the you know the
country became successful in lots of
ways we were inventive you know because
we still had a brand we still believed
in ourselves what worries me much more
is if people lose their belief in in in
anything right there's no substitute and
I I don't think it's going too far to
say that this has contributed to the
rise of some forms of religious
extremism among the children of
immigrants if you if you grow up in a
country where patriotism is scorned and
where if you've got any history at all
in school it will have been presented to
you as a hateful chronology of racism
and exploitation where every interaction
you had with the state would have taught
you to despise it you're gonna feel
you're gonna be you're gonna start
casting around for something more
assertive right and one thing that the
Salafists do not lack is self-confidence
right they are you know I I don't know
if you you saw how many of the Paris
bombers had come from one district of
Brussels called Mullen Beck which is
very close to where where the European
Parliament is and you it's kind of
obvious when you go there what what the
problem is fairly some people you know
Belgium has the problems of the EU writ
large there's no beltran language
there's no Belgian culture there's no
Belgian history you've got two
completely separate communities who live
side by side Dutch speaking and
french-speaking they read two sets of
newspapers they vote for two sets of
political parties they they use
different banks shops TV channels the
thing the whole works right so no one
really feels Belgian you're either
Flemish or you'll balloon but then what
if you're the child of Moroccan
immigrants in molenbeek what is there
for you to be part of you're not Flemish
you're not well owned Ian you know of
course you're not Belgium ever everyone
has taught you that the nation-state is
finished and is evil and
the rest of it some people bought
distress that most kids in that category
do not become terrorists but some people
are bound to start thinking well there's
got to be some something more meaningful
out there and and they I think are the
ones who are then prey to the the the
people who make the most forceful
argument that you know the bigger the
sacrifice you make the more meaning for
your life is and the more the more it
seems at odds with all the values of the
people around you the better right and
and I think that's what's going on I
think a lot of these people are
attracted precisely by the sense of
glamour attached to something shocking
and extremist rather than by anything
that you and I would understand as
conventional religion or piety and this
is I think my big focus on religion
lately when it comes to upholding
liberalism itself is one of the things
that I fear is that it's very easy to
view liberalism as moral relativism it's
very easy to look at liberalism in its
freedoms and say okay well you're just
saying that everybody's opinion is is
equally correct and in that and that
everybody ought to do whatever they want
that it slides into libertinism and that
if there's no rooted sense of common
good you know that government is either
gonna have to fill it on the left or
that I'm going to fill that with my own
sense of moral certainty you see but I'm
us has been very good at doing this it's
it's a secular republic but it has been
very very good at making people want to
belong and it sometimes does so in in
ways that are very simple and very
straightforward and are exactly the kind
of thing that euro Sophists sneer at and
indeed that sophisticated liberals here
sneer at the flags and the bunting and
the 4th of July celebrations and so on
but actually that makes it very easy for
a newcomer to feel that there is
something to belong to right and and
that's been a miraculously powerful
agent for binding people together for a
very long time
and people are always every generation
of Americans thinks it's coming to an
end of it actually it hasn't right I
mean it there's the one of the things
you can't read the history of this
country without realizing that you know
people are unduly pessimistic the
attitude of every generation of
Americans is immigration has been great
until now but this time it's different
and there's always some apparent reason
why it's gonna be different you know
yeah but up until now they all spoke
English yeah but up until now they were
all persons yeah but up until now they
were all white yeah it always works and
and it will work now you know as long as
you retain a sense of confidence as long
as you project a sense of this is a
country worth coming to and this is my
my biggest beef right cheer up guys I
mean I was watching the the the the
democratic debate last week and one
after another they were telling us that
the you know the economy's in collapse
and people are getting poorer and
children are being left in unchanged
diapers and all this guy come on I mean
this country is a quarter of the world's
economy it could take on the armies of
the next two or three biggest combined
it growth from the first quarter was
like three points something percent you
know jobs have never been better since
the 50s I mean cheer up guys you know
how much there's a reason why people are
risking life and limb to try and come
and live here right and generally when
they arrive they're pretty grateful for
the opportunity you don't you don't take
that risk to go to a country that you
think is a bit crap but what is that
Civic religion going to be what is that
the the the binding ties so we've been
told now that apparently according to
colin kaepernick the flag is a symbol of
American racism and slavery the
Constitution is a hallmark of rich white
property owners who disdained black
folks and folks and women American
history is replete with suffering and
cruelty and 4th of July parades
themselves are indicative so I mean I'd
say two things about that first of all
it is the cheapest kind of bad history
to judge any past generation by our
common standards but especially in this
case when our modern standards came
precisely from the promise of the
Constitution right and the the in other
words the Constitution is being damned
precisely by the set of values that it
created and that you know Martin Luther
King appealed to and and the Frederick
Douglass had appealed to that their
argument was precisely it is because
this Republic is not living up to its
ideals that we should have equality in
that that seems to me a pretty good
story right that they they would have
had I think no truck with this idea that
the whole system was was rigged and was
wrong did the other thing that really
struck me as an outside observer is just
how suddenly how quickly everyone rushed
to pretend to believe something that was
patently absurd right
the idea that the bed
Ross flag was you know I can buy an
argument that you shouldn't wear a flag
on your sneakers right III think that
you could but that was not the problem
and and the the sudden a Peter a rock
saying well yeah you know that we've got
to feel the pain and the pain who was
complaining right people who knew better
within hours said okay that's the new
line and then this was really kind of
Salem witch trial stuff I need to rush
out my condemnation first before
somebody accuses me and that really I
mean I'll tell you if the Betsy Ross
flag stands for anything and actually it
wasn't of course the first flag of the
Republic that is that they're now
largely forgotten Continental colors
which expressed in in its Union flag
iconography the belief that the Patriots
had that they were standing for their
their freedoms as as Freeborn Englishmen
but you know okay
the country is invested with some
mythology the Betsy Ross flag that she
probably didn't invent that you know it
if it stands for anything with all that
mythology attached it's for the idea of
an inclusive Republic that everyone is
part of and the idea that people now
kind of rush to anticipate criticism by
being the first in line to condemn it I
think it is profoundly on American and
this is one of the things that is that
is truly scaring me is I'm seeing all of
these common institutions disappear and
that includes the teaching of of Western
civilized history if you say the phrase
Western civilization you are now
condemned as a sort of xenophobe or some
sort of racist and I've seen the same
thing take place in terms of how people
characterize British history apparently
British history is just a litany of rape
slaughter looting imperialism
colonialism brutality and you know
what's missing is any sense of
perspective so of course Britain has
done things that are sordid and things
that are shameful like America has like
every single country in the world right
country is a collection of human beings
some of whom are saintly some of whom
are a monstrous and and most of whom are
somewhere in the middle right you think
of the extent in terms of time and space
of the British Empire of course it will
contain examples of heroism and examples
of nastiness and everything in between
but I would just say judge by the
relevant standards of that age what
historic Cambridge historian in the
early beginning of the 20th century
called Herbert Butterfield who said the
study of the past with one eye on the
present is the origin of all the sins
and sophis trees in history it is the
essence of what we mean by the word a
historic so I would just say to people
when they say oh the you know Britain or
indeed the u.s. is it was kind of you
know bad for gay people or for women or
whatever okay
in what other country at that time would
you rather have been gay or female or
from an ethnic minority or poor
seriously where he Theo Kia Japan you
know really and and unless there is an
answer to that all of this is
meaningless it is it's though it's the
cheapest kind of virtue signaling it is
a self-righteous contemporary mediocrity
saying I am a better human being than
Thomas Jefferson or Winston Churchill or
whatever right and being able to get
away with it because they've identified
some past attitudes that we no longer
hope so where is this revival gonna come
from we've been talking about it for a
while you know who are gonna be the
leaders in the survival because it seems
a bit much to ask our politicians to do
it yes I really worry about this because
the way I see it the the drive of
identity politics here is instead of
creating let's call it as a civic
liberal backlash they would say no no no
we're all together we're all equal
before the law I think it is much more
likely to create a an identity Rhian
white response which would be wrong for
all the same reasons that the the
current in fact I think it's already
happening right if you when I first came
to this country I didn't really come
across any white Americans who thought
of themselves as white rather than as
Americans I'm afraid that is no longer
true because they've been repeatedly
told by the the woke left that the most
important fact about them is that
they're white and that this is some kind
of original sin and there's nothing they
can do about it and you know it's it's
irrecoverable I'm afraid some people are
bound to respond then by having an
identity politics of their own and a an
immigrant descended multi-ethnic
Republic like this more than almost any
other country cannot afford to let
people do that I'm not talking about you
know I'm not talking about people
having pride in in the hyphenated bit of
their and that's fine you know and and
freedom to congregate and sure you're
gonna have you know Italians or Irish
all of it fine but but when you start
defining people as a legal category
effectively whether it's in terms of you
know universities or jobs or whatever
when you start it when the state starts
defining people by accident of
physiognomy or birth then we are in kind
of apartheid South Africa territory and
that is not something that the United
States should ever contemplate okay so
let's talk for a second about what you
do with most of your time which is
represent the the free trade perspective
so this sort of populist revolution that
is supposedly sweeping the globe which I
find bizarre because a lot of these
populace don't think alike at all it
seems like Donald Trump's platform is
closer to national Ferrara's than it is
to Boris Johnson's it seems like many of
the populist groups in Australia are not
very similar to president Trump's I'm
I'm confused by the word populist first
of all cause it doesn't seem to have a
common definition but beyond that there
seems to be this push now against free
trade where is that coming from
I think free trade is counterintuitive
free trade runs up against instincts and
intuitions that we've evolved you know
for it for a much more dangerous planet
but it the other way around
the trumpian protectionist position
rests on a series of assertions that
sound completely plausible even though
none of them is true but they it sounds
totally reasonable to say something like
we can't carry on with the trade deficit
like this or we need to protect
strategic industries or we can't compete
with low-wage economies or we should be
self-sufficient in food the none of
those things is true and the countries
that have done those things have always
made themselves poorer always always by
a kind of mathematical iron law but they
all sound reasonable like you know you
and I are descended from Paleolithic
hunter-gatherers right we have we
carried deep in our DNA the desire to
hoard food to provide against famine so
translate it to a political level that
means you're always gonna have a
majority of people who say yes of course
we should grow our own food here right
actually the countries that are trying
to be self-sufficient in food are the
ones that open themselves to localized
catastrophe the ones that have diverse
supply
globally the ones that genuinely have
security food you know the kind of me
that is most determinately tried to be
self-sufficient in food anywhere on the
planet Earth North Korea right the the
the country which grows zero food and
imports its own drinking water and
everything is Singapore right where
would you rather live so you have to
keep winning these arguments because
they are they seem implausible and I
think that's that's a big part of it
also there's the the perennial problem
of free trade which is it brings
disbursed gains and concentrated losses
so the steel tariffs here may have
propped up 20,000 jobs possibly in the
steel sector but would have affected
well over a million jobs in everything
else in construction automotives
Aeronautics you know but of course it's
the it's the steel lobby that is aware
and that will vote accordingly whereas
the other people don't really notice so
what do you make of the tucker carlson
argument which is that free trade has
sucked away manufacturing jobs to places
like China a lot of those manufacturing
bases those people are not qualified to
certainly go learn computer programming
and that that's a that's a derisive way
of referring to folks shifting
industries in any case and that lack of
economic opportunity is leading to a
certain amount of societal breakdown
fundamental institutions like marriage
being broken down because of economic
need so isn't some government
involvement necessary to prop those so
I'm really interested by this and you
see the contradiction actually in the
president sweeps half of the tweets are
along those lines you know the world is
laughing at us we're offshoring jobs to
Mexico and China and so on and then the
other half is best employment figures
we've ever had right well they listen
they can't both be true and it's the
second one that's thus accurate yes when
when you have free trade with a lower
wage countries some low paid jobs will
go to that country and many more high
wage jobs will be created in your
country you know in that and that's
basically what happens and but this is a
difficult point I totally get it your
country mine they've they've all largely
made a transition already away from
heavy industry toward services you know
we've gone a bit further than you have
but we're now both largely service based
economies when tech and that isn't
really about free trade that's just
about technological advance and automate
and so on when a steelworks closes that
bothers us much more than when
video-rental chain closes or a travel
agent or it you know other which are all
equally victims of the same
technological advance and I get that I
mean I I have in my constituency I had
an old shipyard chattin docks which
employed 12,000 people that peak it
closed in 1984 just the same moment that
all the steel mills and coal mines were
closing all over Britain and to this day
there are guys there who still get angry
about it that evil witch Margaret
Thatcher she hated the working class she
did this to us out of Satan do you know
what I get it III mean who wouldn't be
mad in their in their position in 40
years old you you've got a perfectly
good job as a welder no fault of yours
suddenly that disappears in you at
you're gonna be a security of course
you'd be furious I'd be fury would but
it's only fair to tell this story to the
end unemployment in that constituency is
now 1.2 percent there are more people
per square inch on the old dockyards
than the world when there were ships
there and what are they doing part of it
is a university a little bit of it is
kind of industrial heritage tourism but
the biggest employer there is the
audiovisual sector it's where they make
all the Midwife it's where they make
Sherlock you know now you know my
maternal grandfather was a shipyard
worker in the West of Scotland on the
Clyde and he had the typical unhealthy
West's cotton lifestyle and he died very
young
I mean 59 60 so I never met him so I
never got the chance to say to him would
you would you have rather kept this
whole industry artificially alive but I
suspect that if he could see what my
cousins and I are doing for a living
instead if he could see us tapping at a
screen instead of hitting metal he would
not hesitate now that is that is a tough
argument to make to the people who are
involved I totally totally get that but
this of all countries is based on the
premise that people are prepared to make
sacrifices so their kids get a better
deal and let's do people the courtesy of
assuming that they are also able to
think long term like that that we cannot
stay you can't we can't with old
industries simply because we already
have them there is going to be a gradual
shift towards new things you know the
next thing is going to be driverless
cars right how many people in this
country drive for a living but I'm
altogether uber drivers bus drivers you
know
cab drivers when that happened so they
were going to be unemployed of course
not of course not like just like you
know phones put telegraphists out of
business or they move on to the next
thing and living standards continue to
rise and I know this is a really
difficult thing for people but there you
know if you could go back in a time
machine to any other time you would find
it tough of them now the progress is
always overtime in one direction in a
Tucker Carlson sat in that chair and
informed me that he would outlaw
self-driving cars specifically to ensure
the the that that truckers were able to
keep their their business because
there's so many of them in the United
States so what do you make of the the
rise of China so you suggested before
that you're in favor of free trade with
China yeah I'm a free trader as well my
only hesitation with regard to China is
the question as to whether we are
actively strengthening a regime that
will that will be opposed to us yeah
yeah I mean in the future I mean and and
that is exactly the right question to
ask you know there are there are issues
of industrial espionage as well which
are not really about a free trade
agreement I mean they're happening now
without for free trading reserves that
you've gotta tackle that but as a
general rule I would say economic
engagement is almost always a way of
driving reform in a good direction
doesn't work every time but the tendency
is always a good one so or let me put it
the other way around
sanctions never work a general economic
sanctions hurt the wrong people and prop
up the government by creating a sort of
siege mentality and allowing the
relatively greater opportunities for
corruption that happen in a more closed
economy and if you think about it not
signing a trade deal is that the weakest
form of trade sanction right so I I mean
I'd have I'd have said the same about
Cuba or whatever it's always better to
engage economically you can by all means
sanction politicians by all means have
personalized micro targeted sanctions
like against the the Madhuri stow regime
in Venezuela but in the long run the aim
surely has to be to try to draw China
into a rules-based international trading
order I mean I suppose that the
counter-argument would be sort of the
Soviet Union that Reagan took a much
harsher stance against open trade with
the Soviet Union and in doing so helped
collapse their economy make it
impossible for them to continue their
expansionism China obviously has been
directing an enormous number of
resources toward expansionism in the
South China
see spending resources in South America
really expanding its tentacles into into
Africa so are we
enriching our enemies and you know if
they aren't rands gently in power I mean
current president G's has been radically
increasing his power radically the right
rather than decreasing his power I
wonder if that theory actually works or
not in other words which countries have
been actually liberalized by free trade
and there's there's heavy free trade in
the look in the run-up to World War one
as well and then World War one happened
and that was sort of the end of free
trade in the region sure sure I mean it
doesn't it doesn't guarantee peace it
makes peace more likely but of course
it's no guarantee I mean you know III
agree I think China is a China is a is a
nasty autocracy which under the current
leadership has become more revanchist
more nationalist and more sabre-rattling
generally but I think the thing that
defeated the the Soviet Union wasn't
really economic sanctions it was
superior military standoff it was it was
the deployment of the the Cruise and
Pershing missiles and then the Star Wars
system and I do think you you may need
to be prepared to challenge China in
quite strong terms over Taiwan if I mean
it over I would say almost every trying
to think of a contiguous country to
China that has not at one time or
another felt Chinese aggression you know
Russia India Hong Kong Vietnam it's you
know Tibet though but I just I I just
don't think it has ever been again you
know it was Saddam or Castro or whatever
they all end up being more propped up by
being able to say look I'm the I'm the
guy leading the country against all
these people who are trying to besiege
us so in one second I ask you the final
question which is what does the United
States need to learn from Britain and
what is Britain need to learn from the
United States I mean asking that
question in just one second if you want
to hear a Daniel Hannan to answer you
have to be a daily water subscriber to
subscribe head on over to daily wire.com
click subscribe you can hear the end of
our conversation over there well Daniel
Hannan thank you so much for stopping by
everyone to have you on for a really
long time in a real pleasure pan keep it
up
gonna keep enjoying the show the ben
shapiro show sunday special is produced
by jonathan hey executive producer
Jeremy boring associate producer Mathis
Glover edited by Donovan Fowler audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Jesuit / title
graphics by Cynthia Angulo the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20